[Musique]
comment vous expliquer le sentiment
anti-français qui existe aujourd'hui
dans plusieurs pays d'Afrique il n'y a
pas de sentiment qui français il y a un
sentiment anti France africain on ne
peut pas se séparer de la France vous
savez je vais dire que nous avons un
lien historique il y a plein d'enfants
qui sont des métiers africains français
des nous avons beaucoup beaucoup d'entre
nous culture africaine française il y a
un sentiment
par exemple nous sommes des êtres un peu
hybrides certes mais il y a pas de
sentiment anti-français et un sentiment
anti-fense africain parce que les
Français africains c'est quoi la France
Afrique d'ailleurs ce sont des hommes et
des femmes africains et français
d'ailleurs qui se sont mises en groupe
pour exploiter le continent africain ils
y font beaucoup de mal les entreprises
en France africaine sont très
florissantes tandis que les conditions
travail dans les entreprises sont
catastrophiques on est comme chez
germinal des Mille Zola c'est une
catastrophe et maintiennent en place des
dictatures ils maintiennent le français
phare qui qui ne permet pas à l'Afrique
d'avoir une souveraineté et souvent
quand les interventions des armées
françaises ont lieu c'est la demande des
Français africains donc c'est eux qu'on
combat ce n'est pas la France qu'on
combat c'est les Français africains
alors vous êtes en train de me dire que
finalement ça arrange tout le monde ça
arrange un peu ceux des Français qui
travaillent en Afrique pas tous mais oui
et aussi les régimes africains qui sont
complices de cela oui ce sont des oui
absolument il travaille même dans la
main et il se joue des sentiments des
uns des autres je m'explique quand les
régimes africains sont en difficulté ils
vont pointer du doigt la France pour que
les la jeunesse africaine s'en prennent
à la France pour sauver leur peau à eux
donc cette histoire
sentiment qui français est-ce que les
Français se font agresser en Afrique
jamais
ce sont les entreprises France africaine
qui sont agressés ce sont les Francs
africains qu'on ne veut plus quand on
dit bon évidemment quand tu as ce genre
de mouvement d'humeur vous avez toujours
un peu des extrémistes qui vont dire
tout et n'importe quoi mais ce qui les
extrémistes mais c'est à qui toujours
des gens pas éduqués qui qui ne savent
pas de quoi il s'agit et il y a aussi la
manipulation comme je dis des politiques
qui envoient leurs gammes manifester
devant les ambassades françaises mais ça
n'a rien à voir avec nous quelle liste
mais il y a là pourtant il y a plusieurs
présidents français qui se sont succédés
qui ont dit la France Afrique c'est
terminé qui ont fait cette promesse y
compris d'ailleurs le président Manuel
Macron qui dit la France Afrique c'est
le temps de Jacques focard c'est-à-dire
l'homme de l'Afrique de général de
Gaulle de Georges Pompidou et de Jacques
Chirac d'ailleurs aussi c'est fini ça on
estime qu'il y a plus ces agents euh un
filtré qui font que c'est un la France
Afrique c'est une espèce de société
secrète dans laquelle on ne peut pas
rentrer et qui pilote tout c'est la
France Afrique c'est elle qui a encore
là et c'est contre elle quand on parle
d'arriva c'est un peu la France a raison
quand on parlait de parler de Bolloré il
est parti il se mettre en accord avec
ses régimes c'est pour ça qu'ils sont
combattus ce n'est pas parce que c'est
la France quand vous regardez le
panafricanisme qui domine en fait
idoliquement l'Afrique aujourd'hui la
France fait partie de de de de de de
considérations des panafricains quand on
on vous parle de moi je peux en parler
parce que je fais partie des cerveaux
du panafricanisme le français fait
partie des langues retenues pour pour
l'Afrique de demain pour venir toutes
les Français le français l'anglais
l'arabe le swahili et le pull voilà les
cinq langues retenues donc je ne
comprends pas pourquoi
pas cette confusion entre le
panafricanisme et le sentiment que vous
appelez anti-français qui est un
sentiment anti-frasse africain je n'ai
jamais entendu quand ils disent le
français ça veut dire que leur langue
force c'est de la France a pris notre
temps c'est un sentiment dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler au Mali là où il
y a eu
l'armée française est intervenue pour
lutter contre le djihadisme cette
intervention française qui a duré pas
loin de 7-8 ans et bien elle a été très
mal vécue et aujourd'hui les Français se
sont retirés sous pression du Mali oui
mais pourquoi quand est-ce que ça
intervient ça intervient après l'affaire
de la Côte d'Ivoire et de la Libye
j'avais eu des discussions avec Gayant
là-dessus je voyais d'autres ministres
de l'intérieur du président Sarkozy oui
oui et on échangeait beaucoup on se
voyait à peu près une fois tous les
trois semaines il me recevait pour faire
le point sur ce qu'il fallait faire ou
pas et j'avais dit non j'avais dit nous
allons perdre l'Afrique sous nous y
allons il ne faut pas le faire il est
vivant il m'écoute en ce moment et
personne ne m'a écouté d'ailleurs je me
suis vexé pour ça parce que nous sommes
allés à la catastrophe quand on l'ont
est arrivé il m'a dit qu'elle est on ne
va pas intervenir au Mali j'ai dit il
faut surtout pas le faire on va avoir
des problèmes la France va être dans le
dans le viseur comme le pays qui fait du
mal à l'Afrique donc on y va pas il me
dit qu'elle est vraiment on y va pas je
te le jure et puis c'est tombé j'appelle
François demain cher frère tu m'as
promis que on y allait pas parce que
quand on y va on va oui il était content
parce qu'il y a eu quand il est arrivé
ces espèces de le plus beau jour de sa
vie
je m'en souviens mais j'étais en 2013
oui je savais que ça serait mal passé
j'ai eu un avait parlé je lui ai écrit
des textos SMS en ce sens là il ne m'a
pas écouté c'est tellement content il y
a eu des enfants qu'on ne va appeler
Hollande
il a pas une voix pas loin ce qui pose
réellement problème c'est la
décolonisation c'est pas tant le
colonialisme que la décolonisation que
c'est très mal passé avec le fait qu'on
a mis en place ce qui voulait moins les
indépendants c'est-à-dire des régimes
qui voulaient faire à Miami avec la
France oui que ce qui voulait vraiment
l'indépendance et et le panafricanisme
or le panafricanisme le but ultime des
fondateurs de l'Afrique c'est nous
allons vers ça donc il y avait déjà ce
problème là il fallait que à un moment
donné la France face comme le
Royaume-Uni quel serait-il un peu de
certaines choses et qu'elle crée
d'autres types de relations que j'ai
d'abord d'ailleurs proposé quand j'ai
écrit la francophonie des peuples qui a
été adopté par les 56 états il était
question de créer d'autres types de
relations avec l'Afrique on serait bien
aujourd'hui au lieu de maintenir quelque
chose de non viable et qui fait que les
peuples africains se sentent mal dans
leur peau il y a un nom ça me paraît
très important de revenir là-dessus
parce je sais que vous l'avez bien connu
c'est moi marcadafi et c'est vrai que
l'attaque contre le régime de Kadhafi
donc là on est en 2011 2012 Kadhafi
avait une influence énorme sur l'Afrique
subsaharienne jusqu'à au Bénin jusqu'à
au Burkina Faso jusqu'au Côte d'Ivoire
et ben ça chute à entraîner je dirais un
développement du djihadisme justement
très important c'était une faute énorme
ça bah c'était la plus grosse erreur qui
a été faite d'abord un parce que Kadhafi
d'été c'est les islamistes ils étaient
déjà là mais comme on dit en Afrique il
avait posé un pied sur leur gorge ne
bougez pas parce que Kadhafi était là il
ne blague pas avec eux il est il est
enfermé des canavait un quelque part
donc il ne pouvait pas prospérer ça
c'est vrai la deuxième chose c'est que
Kadhafi était très aimé par les
Africains c'est pas parce que vous
n'aimez pas quelqu'un oui il était bah
oui c'est pour ça que la France a des
problèmes jusqu'aujourd'hui il y avait
ce tu es là moi j'ai travaillé sur le
panafricanisme c'est lui qui a fait
passer d'ailleurs l'idée de l'UA à lui
là j'étais là avec lui l'Union africaine
voilà donc et il travaille avec les
Africains beaucoup sur ce panafricanisme
qui devait voir le jour en 2025 et qui
malheureusement ne voit pas le jour en
tant que disons institution mais existe
puisque tous les parents tous les jeunes
africains sont pas en Afrique alors il y
avait un peu d'opportuniste chez lui
quand même si vous me permettez
au début il voulait succéder à Nasser
faire le pas d'arabisme et puis il a les
pays Arabes l'ont envoyé balader et donc
du coup il s'est retourné vers les les
Noirs africains c'est un peu ça qui
s'est passé quand même hein peut-être
mais ceci étant il n'était pas il était
plutôt pour nous une protection je vais
dire aujourd'hui on a beaucoup à rames
Boko Haram c'est un groupe djihadiste
islamiste donc fait beaucoup de mal
notamment en Cameroun au Cameroun au
Nigeria
qui détruit les villages qui tuent les
jeunes filles qui veulent aller à
l'école je veux dire que la mort de
Kadhafi a été pour l'Afrique un recul de
100 ans et pour la France pour la France
la perte des relations avec l'Afrique
pas complètement parce qu'il y a quand
même encore des relations qui peuvent
être bonnes entre l'Afrique et la France
on pense notamment à pays comme le
Sénégal si vous regardez il y a des
relations qui sont quand même
continuent je dirais qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de tous ces jeunes vous disiez
que c'était surtout contre la France
Afrique qu'ils en avaient mais quand
même qui veulent un changement
bien des relations entre l'ancienne
puissance coloniale où les anciennes
puissances coloniales et l'Afrique qui
disent nous on veut se développer par
nous-mêmes il faut respecter notre
identité faut respecter notre façon de
faire qu'est-ce que vous pensez de tout
ça ça fait partie des mouvements que
j'ai crié ce n'est pas né d'aujourd'hui
c'est là depuis 25 ans ce sont des
mouvements qui sont nés en France
lors de la préparation des événements
des Africains français vous semblait
oublier une chose ici en France les
Africains français sont un groupe de
français noirs certes mais qui ont
toujours impulsé toute la pensée noire
dans le monde et que ça soit la
négritude c'est un fait d'Africains
français peut s'asseoir tout le monde
Césaire ce sont des c'est ce peuple qui
a toujours et même chez canta Diop c'est
un Africain français
aussi bien sûr on l'oublie
donc je vais dire que tout était là sous
vos yeux sauf que quand vous appeliez
les les intellectuels français blancs à
venir s'associer avec nous pour
travailler une venez jamais il était un
million de fois donc on demandait quoi
on demandait des relations qui changent
c'est-à-dire que on voulait que le franc
CFA soit aboli parce que le même peuple
peut pas se développer avec cette
souveraineté monétaire nous voulions que
l'armée française ne soit plus là pour
protéger les dictatures africaines tout
ce qui est dit là ce sont des choses que
nous avons préparé que aurait pu être
géré dans le calme dans ce pays pas ce
sont nos propres compatriotes qui ont
conçu ce panafricanisme c'est pas né en
Afrique c'est né par ici et et trouver
des solutions je vais dire que on va pas
seulement dire aujourd'hui mais les
jeunes les jeunes ne veulent ils veulent
ce que tout jeune français veut ils
veulent être respectés ils veulent que
leur
identité soit respectée ils veulent que
leur langue soit respectée leur mode de
vie soit respecté bien sûr qu'il y a des
choses à corriger qui seront
naturellement corrigés comme par exemple
tout ce qui touche à la condition de la
femme qu'il faudrait modifier il y a des
tolérance aussi introduire dans ces dans
ce continent là mais c'est tout mais
pourquoi la France a refusé de négocier
avec les panafricanistes kébisément est
assez radical quand même oui mais il y a
pas que
il y a des gens comme moi qui sont
vraiment les porteurs du mouvement au
départ
il est en comédie noir mais il n'est pas
anti français
avec la France quand même hein mais les
Français avant tout vous voulez qu'il
aille où vous voulez qu'il aille où il
est très anti France africain et comme
je le disais c'est que vous savez la
culture et quelque chose qui est une
chose importante quand les gens ne sont
pas cultivés quand vous parlait des
peuples comme ça les la masse qui n'est
pas forcément qui n'a pas forcément
d'outils pour comprendre les mécanismes
du monde pour analyser la géostratégie
ils vont te parler de la France alors
qu'ils veulent dire France-Afrique vous
parlez beaucoup du pas d'africanisme
mais si on regarde aussi les le
continent africain on voit qu'il y a
beaucoup de querelles pour pas dire plus
de frontières de bornage si vous le
permettez cette expression de voisinage
qui est un peu légère mais on peut pas
dire que tous les pays africains
s'apprécient les uns les autres à des
conflits les plus flagrants c'est entre
le Maroc et l'Algérie par exemple à
propos du Front Polisario et là on peut
dire que c'est quand même très très
chaud la relation entre les deux pays
effectivement si il est il est évident
que l'Algérie c'est toujours tourné vers
l'Afrique le Maroc vient de rejoindre
l'Union africaine je ne sais pas si vous
êtes au courant voilà donc on ne peut
pas non plus c'est pas parce qu'on parle
du panafricanisme qu'on veut dire qu'il
y a pas de conflit à gérer on a des
conflits comme partout à gérer et mais
c'est pas c'est conflits sont
minoritaires par rapport à l'envie
générale d'aller vers un seul objectif
la France pourrait nous accompagner dans
ce cheminement au lieu de financer une
union africaine parce que l'Union
européenne finance l'Union africaine par
exemple nous disons non des partenariats
oui on nous disant non je veux dire
exactement comme les Français ne veulent
pas que les États-Unis ça
sur leur tête les Africains ne veulent
pas non plus c'est ça va du respect des
peuples de respect du Soi du regard que
qu'on peut porter les uns sur les sur
enfin les uns sur les autres et
d'ailleurs d'abord sur soi-même et
l'amour qu'on a aussi pour soi les
Africains montre-moi dans ce qu'ils
s'aiment cela ne veut pas dire qu'il
déteste l'autre c'est la vie tout
simplement dire discutons aussi il y a
quelque chose qui est assez étonnant en
ce moment c'est l'exemple du Rwanda le
Rwanda
qu'a connu un génocide terrible avec
quasiment un million de morts en 8
semaines
donc une guerre fratricide entre toutes
ci et Hutu c'était en 1994
aujourd'hui quelques moins de 30 ans
après et bien on voit ce pays qui est un
pays complètement
florissant qui est donné en exemple
comme vous expliquer cette renaissance
d'un pays qui a été martyr comme ça tout
ce qui sont venus construire le Rwanda
sont venus d'ailleurs beaucoup sont
venus d'Amérique beaucoup sont venus
d'ailleurs avec d'autres modèles dans
leur tête d'où le rôle important de
diaspora d'accord et effectivement après
ce qui s'est passé le Rwanda était
beaucoup aidé aussi par les pays
européens et autres ce qui n'est pas le
cas des pays africains comme le Cameroun
ou ou le Sénégal et nous en plus en
Afrique centrale puisque vous en parlez
nous sommes restés au 19e siècle pour
l'instant il y a même pas d'alternance à
la tête de nos états du Cameroun
notamment avec un président qui est là
depuis très très longtemps oui il y a
pas que le Cameroun il y a le Congo à
côté pareil ou toute une famille dirige
tout un pays et je vais dire on peut
m'appeler la République que ça
s'ouvre-so de d'Afrique mais alors le
Rwanda comment vous l'expliquez ça en
dehors de l'aide internationale il y a
un homme il faut quand même le
reconnaître je pense que à partir du
moment où tu as un homme intègre ce qui
est le cas de cet homme qu'on l'aime ou
pas le président du Rwanda Paul Kagame
Paul Kagame il est ici de c'est
quelqu'un qui mange je me suis renseigné
un bol de riz par jour pour savoir non
mais il est peuples fonctionnent
beaucoup par mimétisme et les peuples
imitent facilement leurs élites et ils
ont cette chance d'avoir cet homme qui
est très rigoureux et qui qui ne laisse
pas place au pillage au vol
la famille qui prend le dessus sur tout
le reste et qui permet un développement
rapide vous savez même le Cameroun dans
l'état actuel qu'il est malgré tout si
demain matin on a un homme intègre à la
tête du Cameroun tout va changer le pays
va se développer en un clin d'œil vous
savez les masses d'ailleurs c'est quoi
qui en parlait les gens lui ont voulu il
a parlé de premier de cordée moi j'y
crois moi j'y crois parce que dès que
vous avez ces premiers exemples oui ils
savent d'exemple cistorigoureux s'ils ne
veulent pas d'argent s'ils sont honnêtes
si son travailleur immédiatement tous
les peuples vont les imiter travailler
et pourtant Barack Obama qui est
d'origine africaine par son père son
père qui était kenyan disait ce qui
manque à l'Afrique ce sont pas des
hommes forts mais des institutions
solides c'est ce qu'il a toujours dit
mais moi je n'y crois pas parce que ce
sont des sociétés qui fonctionnent
beaucoup par les patriarches encore
d'accord donc il faut des il faut encore
peut-être dans le futur il faudrait
peut-être travailler en même temps que
les institutions fortes sur des figures
charismatiques
rigoureuse et forte et et on le voit au
Rwanda ça a fonctionné
il y a pas beaucoup d'autres exemples
comme ça si je vous parle de Thomas
Sankara oui par exemple en voilà un
exemple mais il a été assassiné il a il
avait la même configuration mentale
quelqu'un mais on lui a pas laissé le
opportunité mais parce que justement la
France ne voulait pas à l'époque de ce
type de développement et ça a value
d'ailleurs à certains
ministres français d'être mis à l'écart
Jean-Pierre cote était le ministre de la
Coopération
justement il était de cette
de cette accabila c'est à dire un homme
rigoureux intègre travailleur donnant
c'était le président du Burkina
c'était aussi un exemple oui absolument
absolument et c'était un homme qui qui
vivait avec peu parce que l'Afrique a
besoin d'un autre type de développement
qu'est-ce que nous vivons aujourd'hui
nous avons des dirigeants boulimiques
tout ils veulent tout ils ont une fin
sans fin ils se ouais frère et il ne
laisse rien à personne tu peux vous
imaginez que par exemple elle est
d'entre eux peut avoir 300 maisons dans
le pays à lui tout seul
ils ont plein de bien partout ici en
France pas seulement bien mais tout son
entourage c'est pas forcément lui en
tant que personne mais ils ne vivent que
comme ça quel est l'exemple qu'il donne
à la jeunesse c'est des hommes très des
braves sexuellement donc du coup les
sociétés sont en train de se de
s'effriter de s'écrouler tellement il y
a plus de modèles de travail on ne dit
plus jeune vous allez travailler vous
allez réussir non nous avons aujourd'hui
à la place des élites intellectuels des
influenceuses qui sont les maîtresses de
ces hommes là que toute la scène sociale
et nos jeunes ne pensent plus qu'à ça et
ça c'était un drame pour nous c'est un
drame est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
cette phrase de Mohamed VI qui n'a pas
prononcé lui-même mais qu'il a fait
prononcer par son premier ministre lors
d'une session à l'ONU aux Nations Unies
le premier appel que je lance du haut de
cette tribune donc audacieux à New York
est un appel pour le respect des
spécificités de chaque pays dans son
itinéraire national aujourd'hui ces
états ceux du Nord n'ont pas le droit
d'exiger des pays du Sud un changement
radical et rapide selon un schéma
étranger alors culture leur principe et
leurs atouts propres comme si le
développement ne pouvait se réaliser
qu'à l'aune d'un modèle unique le modèle
occidental si vous êtes d'accord avec ça
je suis assez d'accord avec ça mais pas
totalement d'accord alors dites-moi je
vais dire qu'il y a des choses quand
même qu'on peut copier de l'autre qui
sont de très belles choses
on pourrait par exemple copier de
l'Occident son modèle de développement
social de la France par exemple avec ses
hôpitaux gratuits c'est ces écoles pour
tous ou même la couverture sociale qui a
été imaginée par le Conseil National de
la Résistance générale de Gaulle oui
mais on pourrait oui je veux dire on
peut pas tout rectifier nous on a pas ça
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on ait ça il y a
des choses qu'on peut prendre chez
l'autre on ne peut pas dire que parce
que c'est l'autre il n'a rien de bon il
y a toujours une évolution à faire à
travers ce que l'autre a fait et qui est
bien on n'est pas obligé de tout copier
effectivement on n'est pas en train de
dire qu'il faut absolument bannir tout
ce qui est africain nous avons des
cultures africaines qui sont propres il
y a dans cette culture des choses
défaillantes dans ces cultures parce que
il y a pas qu'une culture africaine
comme vous savez quand vous les analysez
vraiment par le fond c'est très cousin
oui c'est pour ça que le panafricainisme
fonctionne c'est à dire qu'en fait il y
a même pas tant de langue africaine que
ça il y a trois groupes de langues c'est
tout il y a les langues parlées par les
2500 dialectes quand même hein
mais quand vous quand vous les découpez
là il y en a il y a trois groupes les
langues des grands africains les langues
des des Bantous et de ceux du Sud
[Musique]
les langues comme on les appelle le
swahili c'est tout je veux dire que les
cultures sont tout ce qui est condamnés
par exemple au Sénégal et condamné au
Cameroun en Afrique du Sud on mange
presque tous de la même façon on a des
cultures beaucoup plus similaires
que que l'Europe par exemple donc en
partie seulement en partant
on peut pas vivre en autarcie tout ce
que l'Afrique fait n'est pas n'est pas
forcément bien il y a de très belles
choses mais il y a aussi des choses qui
ne sont pas très belles par exemple
quand on faisait des filles à 9 ans j'ai
dit non les filles doivent aller à
l'école on pourrait imiter cet exemple
de société occidentale d'aujourd'hui
valorisé par exemple le travail mieux
payer les employés que les employés et
par exemple qui ne savent pas des
esclaves qu'ils aient par exemple
découvert une couverture sociale qui
soit respectée qu'ils aient un endroit
ils peuvent aller porter plaine pour
leurs droits je veux dire qu'il y a des
choses qu'on pourrait s'éviter
des drames en égalité homme-femme pardon
l'égalité homme-femme
si vous deviez constituer un panthéon
vous mettriez l'heure dedans d'abord
c'est quant à Dieu pour commencer cher
Anta Diop donc grande historien vous
c'est des galets la l'Université de
Dakar porte son nom et 50 à dire par
notamment une un des sujets de recherche
c'est de dire que une partie des
pharaons était d'origine nubienne
c'est-à-dire noir oui pourquoi et pas
c'est pas seulement à cause de ça c'est
parce que en fait il va redonner à ce
peuple africain qui a connu l'esclavage
et la colonisation une fierté et c'est
important dans la construction de
l'identité des peuples et donc c'est
pour ça que je le
demandez l'apparition oui
Nelson Mandela qui pourtant à la fin de
sa vie à une mauvaise presse parce
qu'elle a eu des démêlés avec la justice
mais qui a été fondamentalement
importante dans la lutte contre la
parted je pense que si oui Mandela
n'avait pas existé le combat de Mandela
n'aurait jamais abouti c'est elle qui
s'est dépatouillée pour que le monde
entier sache que son mari était enfermé
qui avait une ségrégation à cet
endroit-là en Afrique du Sud et je pense
que l'histoire ne donne jamais les sa
place aux femmes or minimum de là mérite
sa place au panthéon Mandela oui il a
été en prison pendant 27 ans et pendant
le 27 ans qui a travaillé et et je vais
dire que effectivement comme vous faites
des choses vous faites des erreurs aussi
il n'y a que ceux qui ne font rien à qui
on peut pas reprocher de défaillance
qui d'autre et j'avais choisi mon beau
petit alors Bongo Betty c'est un
écrivain
qui est un écrivain camerounais
je vous laisse dire pourquoi vous l'avez
prendre conscience aux Africains de la
notion de la France Afrique
avec sa même base sur le Cameroun
notamment
voilà le pauvre crise de Bamba etc mais
c'est surtout cette son travail qui a
permis vraiment aux gens de la
génération qui suivaient comme moi
l'existence même d'accord
nigérian ni pour le coup
de place en Afrique aux intellectuels et
qui est bien écrit un livre le monde
s'effondre et ce monde s'effondre nous
fait nous fait prendre conscience de
de la fin des choses qui a rien qui
éternel et le monde s'effondre a fait
prendre conscience aux Africains que
leur monde d'attente était fini et qu'il
fallait qu'il se reconstruise et ça
c'est pas mal merci Félix merci à vous
[Musique]